all right because this is such an easy
thing to screw up okay let's start
simple again with a number okay so
polynomial long division is built on
numerical long division yes
so let's pick some numbers like say 7
how about that okay let's see what we
get so how does well rehearse the steps
in me what's a very first thing that I
do good I say this is the thing that
I've divided by this isn't here I'm
dividing okay by the way what are they
cold again divisor and which we chose
this isn't the question or is it the
dividend question dividend this is so
funny I let you look it up let's come
back we look at how much the devised are
fitted to to be unambiguous the big
number the big dumber okay now just
seven feet two three answer so you're
right down 0 you're made to write down 0
so then you have to go a little further
to see if you can get a 7 into that and
the answer is you can
how many okay now what did we do that
for
multiplied out the front okay now we're
going to do this step this is the one
which starts to repeat over and over
again right
you subtract okay then you your pick can
you fit seven into two and two know at
least you shouldn't be able to otherwise
you need 28 wrong right so now therefore
I bring that zero down and I do it again
how many times what multiply subtract
now here I've got no more numbers to
bring down okay and that's why I'm
finished so that's my remainder okay now
it's really important that what you get
out of this is what we call the division
transformation do you remember that
division transformation not so this has
a vague memory I was like Dana but I
have no idea what it means the division
transformation is is this thing here all
right it's being able to express the
division we just did as a product plus
whatever trailing things we need to
include to make it the correct equation
right so daily I've got seven points to
you right so I should start with a 300
now 300 is equal to 7 by 42 but not
quite because we had this remainder
right so you add 6 ok now it's worth
noting that with all these numbers right
numerical on division your remainder is
always positive okay but we polynomials
it's not always so as you see okay now
let's do
all right let's give this a go shall we
X square plus 5x plus 6 now even though
I don't know what X is this one's got a
higher degree that's why it's 1 there's
my X plus 1 over here right now just
like if I have bigger number here right
like say that was have 2 divided by 17
and not 7 okay which number is it will
actually become bigger we did let's say
17 okay it's not as much value to me to
say well how many times it's for Finn to
300 right it's not that significant
because it's the 74 it's that number at
the front that's how much it takes over
that's not which is really important and
exactly the same way here it's this term
not this one which is the important one
I mean X could be smaller than 1 right
but because it's a variable I don't know
it might be a million so it's like yeah
let's check how many times one goes
through no you checked you how many
times a million goose okay so that's why
I always wanted what four plus one
no he just gets ditched and no one no
one has any fun it's because we which is
more importantly to the X so that's why
you look at X how many times would go in
x times because I don't know what X is
in my example it might be in a million
yeah yeah that doesn't matter so much
here when we do synthetic division in
about five minutes
so my brain just melted okay before we
get to that let's finish this question
Shh
come back come back what do I do with
the X I multiply it back right x squared
now what did I do here over here I
subtract good so I get 4 X 3 the six
down okay what happens here it goes in
nimes you guys are good
Wow okay and then I subtract 1 1
suppliant and I've got nothing more
debris now so that's why I know I'm
finished
ok so let's write this is the division
transformation okay it means that x
squared plus 5x plus 6 which you know
can be factorized in another way right
but if you try and factorize it this way
you get X plus 1 X plus 4 and you have
to add this two of you to make all the
numbers sit